For decades, the ISS has been an icon of international
cooperation.
Two bitter enemies were able to put aside
their differences and embark on a project
that would better all of humanity.
After 23 years though, the ISS is starting
to meet its natural end, and Russia feels
that it’s time to ditch the ISS and build
their own national space station.
So, here’s how Russia plans to withdraw
from the ISS and their progress on their next
space station.
Before we get into Russia’s new space station,
let’s first take a look at why Russia is
leaving the ISS in the first place starting
with of course aging.
The ISS was mostly designed within the 1990s
and the first ISS module was launched way
back in 1998.
So, at this point, astronauts at the ISS are
basically using 20 to 30 year old technology.
Nasa claims that there’s still plenty of
research that can be completed with this technology
itself, but there’s no question that new
modules with up to date technology would make
the process much smoother.
The technology is not the only component that’s
aging either, the overall body and exterior
of the ISS is deteriorating as well.
Space is an extremely unforgiving place with
large amounts of radiation, super cool temperatures,
and a plethora of space debris.
Scientists did design the ISS to withstand
all of the harsh forces found in space, but
as the ISS ages, the likelihood of some component
giving in is much higher.
Just a few years ago, astronauts aboard the
ISS noticed a drop in pressure.
After a little digging, they found that there
was a small hole in the walls of the ISS.
They did quickly fix the issue and no one
was hurt, but this incident makes it clear
that serious problems can and have occurred.
Russia actually points to safety being the
primary reason that they are leaving the ISS.
Last month, the Deputy Prime Minister of Russia,
Yury Borisov, stated quote, “We can't risk
the lives [of our cosmonauts].
The structure and the metal [are] getting
old, [and] it can lead to irreversible consequences
— to catastrophe."
Another major consideration when it comes
to keeping the ISS running is funding.
The ISS costs a massive $150 billion to construct.
We don’t know how much money Russia spends
on the ISS every year, but we do know that
Nasa spends $3 to $4 billion annually to keep
the ISS international.
Assuming that Roscosmos spends a similar amount,
Russia is throwing at least a few billion
dollars at the ISS every year.
By implementing all of the experience Russia
has gained from operating the ISS, it’s
likely that they can build a new space station
that’s much cheaper to run.
Something else to consider is that Nasa just
recently stopped subsidizing Russia’s portion
of the ISS.
Since Nasa retired the space shuttle, they
had been relying on Soyuz rockets to send
US astronauts to the ISS.
It’s estimated that between 2011 and 2019,
Nasa spent a hefty $3.9 billion to fly US
astronauts on Soyuz rockets.
This revenue no doubt reduced Russia’s net
input into the ISS.
But, starting last year, Nasa started to rely
on SpaceX for crewed ISS missions.
Starliner also just completed its first fully
successful uncrewed ISS mission, so Nasa now
has two different options to send astronauts
to the ISS.
As a result, I don’t think they’re going
to be buying tickets on Soyuz anytime soon
meaning that Russia has to fork over more
of their own money to keep the ISS running.
And this simply doesn’t make sense for Russia
when both them and NASA are ready for the
next step.
You see, the ISS is not the end goal when
it comes to space exploration.
The long term goal is to return to the moon
and get people to mars and so on and so forth.
So, neither NASA nor Russia are interested
in spending the majority of their effort on
the ISS.
Nasa is looking to finally return humans to
the moon in 2024 and Russia is working on
putting humans on the moon themselves by 2030.
In the meantime, Nasa is planning to open
up the ISS to private astronauts and tourists.
While I don’t think Russia has any objection
against this plan, I also don’t think they
really care to spend manpower on supporting
the effort long term.
So, those are some of the primary reasons
that Russia is looking to ditch the ISS.
Fortunately, they’re not just pulling out
of the partnership without an ample warning
time.
Russia said that they will confirm or extend
their departure date in 2025 meaning that
Russia has given the ISS partners a minimum
of 5 years to prepare for their departure.
Whether they leave in 2025 or 2030 is really
just dependent on how well their own space
station development goes.
Russia started working on this new space station
in 2015, and they hope to have it ready for
launch by 2025.
If they are able to meet this deadline, the
next goal is to put the entire station in
orbit by 2030 at which point Russia would
completely exit the ISS.
Something that we should note though is that
Russia said this exact same thing 6 years
ago with different dates.
In 2015, Russia announced that they were going
to leave the ISS in 2020 and move into their
own space station in the early 2020s.
But clearly, that didn’t happen, so it's
very possible that these deadlines are pushed
back once again.
I do think that Russia is much more motivated
to transition now that Nasa is no longer dependent
on them.
However, space technology almost always takes
longer to develop than expected, so a more
realistic timeframe may be completing the
space station by 2030 and putting it into
orbit by 2035.
At that rate, Russia would stay on the ISS
for another 15 years.
Nasa is looking to deorbit the ISS in the
2030s or 2040s, so at that point, Russia may
ironically end up sticking with the ISS till
the end of its life.
What will happen to Russia’s ISS modules
though?
Well, Russia was originally discussing disconnecting
the modules and connecting it to their upcoming
space station.
But given the age of the older modules, it’s
very possible that Russia simply retrieves
some parts of them to be placed in museums
and lets nasa deorbit the rest of the ISS.
Anyway, moving onto the new space station,
Russia is aiming for the new station to cost
just $5 billion and it is being manufactured
by Energia corporation.
The new space station is called the Russian
Orbital Service Station or ROSS.
The station is expected to have 3 different
docking ports.
1 for Soyuz crewed vehicles and 2 for Progress
cargo ships.
As for the core part of the station itself,
we have 5 different modules with the first
being the airlock module.
As the name suggests, this module acts as
an airlock for the space station.
But more importantly, this module contains
the spacewalk hatch.
Next up, we have the transformable module.
This module is unique as it can expand and
constrict it’s internal volume.
Once it’s attached to the space station,
there’s really no reason to constrict the
volume of the module, but launching it in
its constricted orientation would save space
on the launch vehicle.
This module is expected to have exercise facilities
and likely sleeping and restroom facilities
as well.
As for the Prichal node module, this module
is supposed to serve as the core of the space
station and connect all of the different modules
together.
The space station is also slated to have a
gyroscopic module, but we don’t have details
as to the purpose of the module.
Anyway, the last two modules are all science
and research modules with the first being
the Nauka module.
The Nauka module was actually originally designed
to be docked with the international space
station, but Russia decided to repurpose the
module to be used in their own space station.
This module is officially a multi purpose
laboratory, but it also has a robotic arm,
a science airlock, a radiator, and a couple
of orbital correction engines.
Finally, we have the science and power module
which is apparently the most advanced portion
of the space station.
Not only will it have leading edge laboratories
and flight control systems, but it will also
offer extra living quarters.
Aside from all of these modules, the station
will of course have solar panels and propellant
tanks to power the station and its engines.
The entire station is estimated to have a
pressurized volume of 220 cubic meters.
To put that in perspective, the ISS has a
pressurized volume of about 1000 cubic meters.
The russian portion of the ISS is only 189
cubic meters though, so the ROSS is larger
than the Russian part of the ISS.
But in comparison to the overall ISS, the
russian space station is about 1/5th to 1/4th
of the size of the ISS.
Considering the smaller size of the station,
it is estimated that 2 cosmonauts will stay
at the station for 2 month periods at a time.
Russia plans to put the space station in a
lower orbit than the ISS in the 300 to 350
km altitude range.
Aside from being in a lower orbit, the space
station will also follow a different orbital
path than the ISS.
The Russians want to put their station in
polar orbit in order to monitor northern sea
routes.
They’re hoping to create new shipping routes
through the arctic as the arctic ice melts.
On top of creating new arctic routes, Russia
is looking to get a much better view of mainland
russia.
Right now, Russia is only able to view about
20% of their territory from the ISS which
has been one of their top complaints from
the very beginning.
With polar orbit, Russia should be able to
view most of their territory unlike with the
ISS.
Aside from building their own space station
for the earth, Russia is also partnering with
China to build a lunar space station.
This actually sounds extremely similar to
Nasa’s lunar gateway project, but Russia
isn’t really interested in participating
in the lunar gateway project.
They say that the Lunar gateway is way too
US centric.
They are, however, open to allowing other
nations to use their lunar space station once
it is complete.
But that’s pretty much all we know about
the russian chinese lunar space station at
this point in time.
At the end of the day, the ISS was a revolutionary
project both scientifically and diplomatically.
As the ISS continues to age and space technology
continues to advance though, it makes less
and less sense to support the ISS, especially
with larger projects around the corner.
NASA themselves is looking to pull the plug
on the ISS within the next 10 to 20 years,
but it looks like Russia isn’t willing to
wait that long.
So, they’re basically putting in their 5
years notice as they look to build their own
space station within this decade.
The station isn’t nearly as large as the
ISS, but it is expected to be significantly
cheaper, more efficient, and much more useful
to the Russians.
Aside from this, they’re also looking to
partner with China to build a lunar space
station, but we’ll just have to wait and
see how that turns out.
What do you guys think about Russia’s plan
to ditch the ISS?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you guys are excited
to see more space stations being launched.
And of course, consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.